bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
on revient sur l'actualité économique
locale et on commence avec les titres
une taxe de séjour pouvant aller jusqu'à
8 euros la nouvelle mesure du Parlement
inquiète les professionnels du tourisme
d'autant qu'une taxe additionnelle de 2
euros est prévue en Île-de-France nous
étions ce mardi à l'Assemblée Générale
de la Maison de l'Entreprise l'occasion
de tirer le bilan sur cette année et les
projets à venir
et pour beaucoup d'étudiants les
vacances ont commencé et pourtant il
faut déjà penser au logement pour la
rentrée quels sont les bons plans
réponse dans notre dossier de la semaine
nous retrouverons également Daniel
Taravella bonsoir vous êtes le président
départemental de la Fédération française
du bâtiment vous organisiez vendredi
dernier votre assemblée générale nous
reviendrons du coup sur la situation
actuelle et également sur vos positions
dans l'entretien mais avant on passe aux
infos de la semaine
coup dur pour les professionnels de
l'hôtellerie le Parlement a voté une
hausse considérable de la taxe de séjour
les communes reconnues comme station de
tourisme pourrait quintupler cet accéder
la rentrée Mathilde cap Berne et Yolaine
Torres
les taxes de séjour pourraient connaître
des aménagements deux amendements ont
été votés la semaine dernière l'un
prévoit une augmentation possible de
500% pour les hôtels 3 4 et 5 étoiles
passons ainsi de 1 euro 50 à 8 euros
l'autre spécifique à la région
Île-de-France planifie une taxe
additionnelle de 2 euros le but financer
les transports en commun de la région
par exemple une famille de quatre
personnes passent une nuit dans les
Yvelines pour à payer jusqu'à 40 euros
au lieu de 6 actuellement une mesure
jugée trop importante pour le
département du Tourisme des Yvelines
soit impact le visiteur de touristes
directement soit à ça impacte l'hôtelier
qui lui verra ses marges réduites et par
les temps qui courent avec effectivement
les baisses de fréquentation qui peuvent
être engendrés par la crise c'est pas
une période extrêmement favorable pour
faire ça la région Île-de-France est
l'une des destinations les plus visitées
au monde la crainte que les visiteurs
est plutôt vers la concurrence comme
Londres ou les pays de l'Est la solution
pour le département augmenter la qualité
des hébergements pour défier cette
concurrence mais attention cette
nouvelle contribution est plafonnée à 8
euros les mairies pourront fixer leurs
prix en revanche la taxe additionnelle
de 2 euros est imposée dans les Yvelines
neuf communes ont adopté la taxe de
séjour
et donc même si c'est 8 euros ne sont
qu'un plafond cette mesure est fortement
critiquée même dans la majorité Laurent
Fabi sans tête les aménagements
pourraient donc voir le jour bilan
positif pour la Maison de l'Entreprise
cette institution organisée mardi son
assemblée générale en présence de ses
partenaires les actions passées et à
venir dans ce reportage réalisé avec
Juliette poussin
la Maison de l'Entreprise adressée son
bilan hier en compagnie de ses
partenaires cet outil créé par la
Communauté d'Agglomération contribue au
développement économique du territoire
parmi leurs actions des rendez-vous avec
des créateurs des permanences d'experts
des visites d'entreprises mais surtout
un accompagnement des porteurs de
projets sur l'année 2013 2014 la maison
de l'entreprise a accompagné 720 projets
soit 3700 heures de conseils elle a
ainsi permis la création de 300
entreprises avec ses partenaires les
acteurs économiques publics et privés du
territoire elle cherche à aller encore
plus loin l'association Delta Sky a par
exemple proposé de créer un incubateur
il faut pas que Paris aspire tout il
faut aussi que les autres territoires
puissent avoir leur propre incubateur
alors sans concurrence mais en
complémentarité
dès qu'il y a des projets un peu plus
industriels il faut aller mettre ces
entreprises au plus près des industriels
qui vont être leurs clients donc des
incubateurs dans des territoires de
première ou seconde couronne parisienne
sont idéalement placés pour ça car
l'accent se rapportait l'année prochaine
sur l'innovation notamment pour
favoriser l'emploi on a tout intérêt
nous en tant qu'appuie collectivité
appui de public à favoriser la création
on va dire à haut niveau pour ensuite
décliner des emplois qui pourraient se
développer sur le territoire donc ça
c'est une première démarche et puis on a
beaucoup parlé aussi des entreprises en
difficulté pour cela la plateforme
initiative a mis en place des prêts
conjoncturels d'autres projets sont à
l'étude le possible élargissement de la
communauté d'agglomération des 50 ans en
Yvelines pourrait également redessiner
le champ d'intervention de la maison de
l'entreprise est envisager l'intégration
de Maurepas et Coignières d'un côté et
plaisir Villepreux et Les
Clayes-sous-Bois de l'autre décision
prise en janvier 2015
au solar Décathlon de Versailles on ne
construit pas que des habitations on y
fait aussi du business près de 80
entreprises se sont retrouvées au stand
de la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
l'occasion de parler à faire et
technologies de demain des images de
Juliette poussin
le Solar Décathlon une compétition
internationale où s'affront des dizaines
d'étudiants le but construire un habitat
utilisant le soleil comme seule source
d'énergie mais ce 2 juillet on y
rencontrer pas que les compétiteurs près
de 80 dirigeants d'entreprises ont
participé à une journée d'affaires des
rencontres individuelles pour présenter
ses produits et ses services et faire du
business un lieu pas si atypique car
toutes les entreprises présentes
travaillent autour des nouvelles
technologies et de la ville du futur
comme par exemple ce drôle de masque je
vous présente le Dolphin qui est le
premier objet communicant sous-marin qui
était c'est une console qui équipait
d'un tablette PC une caméra haute
définition du wifi du GPS et l'objectif
c'est de déporter d'apporter les loisirs
numériques en mer notamment pour la
rando des palmées ou la police Soumagne
pour développer son produit en un temps
réduit il souhaite favoriser les
entreprises locales c'est très pratique
de se rendre compte que quand les
Yvelines il y a toutes les compétences
liées à des développements innovants que
ce soit au niveau logiciel marketing
voir production de produits industriels
face à lui Olivier Clavet peut-être un
futur partenaire sa société
d'informatique pourrait lui créer un
logiciel embarqué en réalité augmentée
toute la journée les entrepreneurs ont
enchaîné les rendez-vous un événement
mis en place par la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie des Yvelines pour
répondre à une demande forte vous êtes
voisins de palier ou voisins d'immeubles
et à ne jamais avoir de discussion off
the office et ne jamais voir émerger des
idées intéressantes et vous retrouvez
ici et précisément dans un cadre
particulier pouvoir voir émerger des
idées du business donc je pense que
c'est comme ça que ça marche l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine Smart dez
auront pour thème l'économie circulaire
le Solar Décathlon quant à lui se
terminera le 14 juillet
et le stand de la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie reste ouvert jusqu'à demain
vous pourrez y découvrir les innovations
technologiques et des entreprises
illinoises un autre rendez-vous
d'affaires à Paris Saclay cette fois
aujourd'hui 10 entreprises sélectionnées
ont pu dévoiler dévoiler leurs projets
et trouver des financeurs lors du parc
Paris Saclay invest parmi à une
plateforme de vente de vêtements en
ligne par exemple avec possibilité
d'essayage en 3D ou encore la console
subaquatique Dolphin que nous venons de
voir dans le précédent reportage
une crèche privée était une augurée ce
mardi à Saint-Cyr un moyen de combler le
manque de place d'accueil pour les
tout-petits et l'occasion pour nous de
faire le point sur les sorts du privé
dans ce secteur de la petite enfance des
images de gilet de poisson
en France on estime qu'il manque
aujourd'hui de 300 à 500000 places
d'accueil pour les enfants de moins de 3
ans face à cette pénurie les entreprises
de crèches privées se développent
rapidement un marché qui a progressé de
33% par an de 2017 les crèches publiques
restent encore largement majoritaire
mais les fondements exemple à Saint-Cyr
où le maire inauguré mardi la crèche Les
Minipouss ce lieu est géré par
l'entreprise la maison bleue un moyen
pour la ville de proposer des places à
ses habitants en minimisant les dépenses
pour la ville effectivement c'est
beaucoup moins cher puisque la ville ne
paye pas la construction c'est la maison
bleue qui paye la construction et qu'au
bout du contrat qui a un contrat assez
long naturellement la ville récupère le
bien pour le fonctionnement comme une
bonne partie des places sont
commercialisées auprès d'entreprise qui
paye les places pour leur salarié en
fait la ville ne paye qu'une partie du
fonctionnement car sur les 40 places
d'accueil proposées la moitié réservée à
la municipalité l'autre aux entreprises
pour les parents le coût reste identique
à celui d'une crèche municipale pour ses
spécialistes de la petite enfance
l'objectif est aussi de se distinguer
pour gagner des parts de marché la
maison bleue mais l'accent sur le
développement durable niveau pédagogie
on insiste sur le rythme de l'enfant et
on attache une attention particulière au
repère l'enfant mange toujours à la même
place toujours avec la même personne
dort toujours au même endroit voilà il y
a des choses comme ça qui se répètent
tous les jours et qui crée en fait une
sécurité affective chez l'enfant
autre entreprise de crèches privées les
petits chaperon rouge elle fait partie
des leaders du marché et enregistrent
plus de 100 millions de chiffre
d'affaires ici on adapte les modes
d'accueil en fonction des besoins des
parents spécialistes des crèches
inter-entreprises il propose des places
dans tout le réseau même en urgence dans
le département on compte en totalité
14800 places d'accueil pour les moins de
3 ans dont 378 établissements
et pour cet entretien nous recevons
Daniel Taravella bonsoir vous êtes le
président départemental de la Fédération
française du bâtiment au niveau indiqué
en introduction vous organisez votre
assemblée générale vendredi dernier
c'est donc l'occasion pour nous de faire
le point sur le secteur du bâtiment donc
tout d'abord un mot sur la situation du
marché on estime que 30% des entreprises
du secteur éprouvent des difficultés de
trésorerie en France finalement tout
n'est pas rose tout est loin d'être
heureuse est-ce que vous venez
d'indiquer pour le au plan national
s'avère
identique en ce qui concerne au plan
départemental puisque si vous voulez
pour vous donner quelques chiffres
aujourd'hui nous avons à peu près 83%
des entreprises qui ont un carnet de
commandes qui se limite à deux mois 30%
qui ont un carnet de commandes qui se
limite à un mois c'est-à-dire qu'elle
travaille pratiquement au jour le jour
en 2013 nous avons perdu sur le
département environ entre 800 et 1000
emplois
les prix de marché ne cessent de baisser
aujourd'hui on j'ai pris une marché qui
sont inférieurs au prix de production ce
qui fait que les choses ne peuvent pas
avancer de cette façon là les prix de
base par contre augmentent c'est-à-dire
effectivement les matériaux continuent à
augmenter les charges augmentent bien
évidemment tout au moins c'est notre
sentiment donc le seul chose le seul
chose qui diminue ce sont les prix de
vente et ce qui n'est ce qui pose bien
évidemment le gros problème et si vous
voulez il y a un ratio qui était à peu
près constant ces dernières années à
savoir que en matière de liquidation
d'entreprise le bâtiment a toujours plus
ou moins représenté environ 30%. or sur
les trois ou quatre derniers mois on
peut considérer que c'est monter à 40%.
alors vous l'indiquez depuis vous
l'indiqué quelques mois la concurrence
des loyal a aussi une place dans dans
une des causes pardon c'est toujours le
cas actuellement bien sûr c'est une
cause extrêmement importante
à savoir que beaucoup de d'entreprises
utilisent que j'appelle de la de la un
low cost qui vient d'ailleurs
essentiellement des pays de l'Est mais
sans faire de long discours aujourd'hui
une entreprise sérieuse qui respecte la
législation qui respecte les lois
sociales doivent vendre ses heures les
heures de compagnon entre 60 et 70 euros
et ces gens-là arrivent à se vendre j'ai
dit bien à se vendre à 18 ou 20 euros de
l'heure donc bien évidemment le
différentiel est extrêmement important
et il provient en grande partie du
différentiel de cotisation sociale
puisqu'on considère que le différentiel
entre les pays de l'Est et la France et
de l'ordre de 35%. la loi contre le
dumping social ne changera pas la donne
elle a été votée fin juin alors je pense
que c'est effectivement une avancée
puisqu'elle va permettre de
responsabiliser à certains nombre de
donneurs d'ordre qui jusqu'à présent ne
s'inquiétait pas de tout cela tout ce
qui est intéressant
par exemple qui est en tort cela étant
cela étant subsistera le fait
à cette main d'oeuvre
ne respecte pas les horaires légaux de
travail c'est à dire qu'ils travaillent
facilement 10 ou 12 heures par jour
qu'il travaille le samedi et le dimanche
sans problème et le seul moyen d'y
remédier ce serait de faire des
contrôles un peu plus efficaces mais
chacun sait que les contrôles les
week-ends
alors le cice effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui est intéressant pour
les entreprises ce qu'il faut dire que
très peu de finalement petite entreprise
jusqu'à présent l'ont utilisé parce que
au premier abord même si ça ne m'est pas
réellement ça paraît toujours un petit
peu compliqué donc il y a un mouvement
et d'autre part ce qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est que des entreprises qui pouvaient
demander l'anticipation pouvait le faire
mais ce n'est pas gratuit puisque ça
revenait en quelque sorte à demander une
avance de trésorerie avec un taux
d'intérêt à payer à la banque bon et en
ce qui concerne le pacte de solidarité
le pack de solidarité donc bien
évidemment nous accueillons avec
favorablement tout ce qui est baisse de
charge encore que nous avons tendance à
penser que c'est un petit peu un rendu
de ce qui nous a été amputé au cours des
années précédentes mais aujourd'hui le
gros problème de nos entreprises c'est
l'activité or quelque soit j'allais dire
le niveau de charge si les entreprises
n'ont pas d'activité elles ne peuvent
évidemment pas ni embaucher ni investir
nécessite forcément de la croissance le
compte en pénibilité a été retardé au
tout du moins pour un an c'est une bonne
nouvelle en tout cas pour votre
fédération c'est une bonne nouvelle
effectivement le fait qu'elle soit
retardée maintenant il va falloir tout
de même se pencher sur le contenu
puisque pour le moment le contenu reste
le même que ce qui était or je rappelle
que c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument ingérable au niveau d'une PME
pour vous donner toujours des choses
concrètes
la fameuse fiche de pénibilité qui est
une fiche journalière à tenir par
ouvrier imaginez une entreprise d'une
quinzaine de personnes vous avez un chef
de tromperie une collaboratrice arriver
au bout de l'année ils vont avoir fait
quelque chose comme 3700 ou 3800 fiches
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
impensable alors on va conclure avec les
réformes autour de la transition
énergétique qui sont quand même un gros
point pour l'avenir en tout cas de votre
filière des formations sont mis en place
notamment au sein de votre fédération
pour avoir la reconnaissance Grenelle
Environnement seuls les artisans qui
seront qui auront ce label
permettront en fait d'obtenir des aides
publiques pour les travaux de
performance énergétique je pense au
crédit d'impôt développement durable le
CIDD également à l'écho-prés à taux zéro
là ça se met en place et c'est quelque
chose qui va pouvoir valoriser en tout
cas vos artisans que c'était un marché
qui était un petit peu en sommeil parce
que ça a un coût pour pour les clients
mais c'est vrai que le plan qui a été
annoncé par Madame Royal est une avancée
incontestablement maintenant il va
falloir le traduire dans les faits très
bien je vous remercie beaucoup en tout
cas pour pour votre participation sur ce
plateau merci on passe tout de suite au
dossier de la semaine
à peine les examens terminés les
milliers d'étudiants yvelinois partent à
la recherche de leur logement pour la
rentrée une étape dans laquelle il n'est
pas toujours évident de s'y retrouver
nous avons rencontré cette certains
acteurs du département qui permettent de
faciliter les démarches ainsi que des
étudiants qui reviennent sur leur
expérience un dossier réalisé par
Yolaine Torres et Romain ruspini avec
l'aide de la rédaction je recherche un
truc 100 minutes de la fac c'est grand
pas trop cher la course au logement a
débuté pour les étudiants en première
année de médecine Agnès profite de ce
forum organisé par l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
pour tenter de trouver son bonheur un
studio aux alentours de 400 euros dans
une résidence universitaire j'ai pas
vraiment eu la possibilité de faire des
recherches super tôt vu que je devais
travailler et mes parents ils avaient
pas non plus beaucoup de disponibilités
donc je me suis pris assez tard au final
et j'avais pas non plus des explications
super claires sur Internet tout ça
étudiant en médecine aussi Jugurta de
son côté s'est fixé un budget de 500
euros maximum
et les recherches semblent plutôt
compliquées je pense que cette année
c'est un petit peu mal parti et je vais
peut-être rester chez mes parents
il y a la PL qui prend à peu près 250
euros mais derrière si un loyer fait 500
euros s'il reste 250 à payer derrière
pour payer ces 250 € restant un petit
job en complément lui semble la
meilleure solution j'ai dit un petit peu
tout le terrain à Carrefour qui m'ont
qui m'ont dit probablement peut-être que
peut-être que pour l'année ça le ferait
mais là aussi il faut voir selon
l'emploi du temps de ma fac si c'est
compatible donc on va voir ce forum
logement est aussi l'occasion de
rappeler quelques règles essentielles il
faut être vigilant sur le loyer savoir
si les charges sont nous sont comprises
ou ne sont pas comprise dans ce loyer et
puis vraiment visiter logement pour pour
s'assurer que tout est conforme à ce qui
avait été convenu par une annonce
établir un état des lieux précis parce
que voilà des fois on n'est pas vigilant
à notre entrée dans les lieux mais
finalement à la sortie du coup ça peut
être après ponctionné sur le dépôt de
garantie laissé par les étudiants ce qui
est vraiment dommage colocation chambre
chez l'habitant ou encore studio
indépendant les offres sont multiples et
variées pour les étudiants pour s'y
retrouver Yvelines informations jeunesse
basée à Versailles propose de rencontrer
des étudiants et de les aiguiller un des
premiers conseils se constituer un
dossier solide il y a des pièces voilà
de base qu'un propriétaire peut demander
notamment une photocopie d'une pièce
d'identité
il peut également lui demander si le
jeune est étudiant un certificat de
scolarité
il peut lui demander également
si le propriétaire va demander un garant
il manquera aussi des pièces par rapport
à ce garant là notamment voilà contrat
de travail du garant avec deux trois
derniers fiches de paye pour voir un peu
près les ressources et savoir si c'est
envisageable ou pas ou pas en fonction
du prix du loyer que demande le
propriétaire ce centre d'informations
propose également un service de mise en
relation entre étudiants et
propriétaires parmi les locations il y a
le studio indépendant résidence d'après
la conseillère prévoir un budget moyen
de 500 euros par mois pour environ 20
mètres carrés pour une centaine d'euros
moins cher il y a aussi les chambres
indépendantes avec cuisiner salle de
bain partagé le bon plan c'est aussi la
chambre chez l'habitant avec un budget
compris entre 300 et 400 euros par mois
en moyenne
mais il y a également la colocation chez
l'habitant c'est le choix qu'a fait
Olivier il y a trois ans se vendait un
arrive à La Verrière pour faire ses
études d'infirmiers il regarde d'abord
les appartements mais se rend compte que
c'est trop cher ils se tourne alors vers
les chambres chez l'habitant via un site
de mise en relation entre particuliers
dès la première visite avec ses parents
c'est le coup de cœur sécher l'habitant
mais au final c'est très indépendant
donc c'est comme un petit studio sauf
qu'après quelques contraintes chez
l'habitant on peut pas forcément quand
un étudiant on aime bien faire les fêtes
c'est un peu pas forcément ramener trop
de monde il faut être respectueux on
n'est pas forcément chez nous mais c'est
indépendant pour 380 euros par mois
toutes charges comprises Olivier dispose
d'un studio entièrement meublé avec une
entrée indépendante donc là c'est à voir
si de la cuisine donc il y a aussi
indépendante juste pour les étudiants
donc on était deux à se partager la
cuisine donc très bien ils étaient deux
en effet durant trois ans à se partager
cuisiner salle de bain les propriétaires
à l'étage eux au rez-de-chaussée une
sorte de colocation chez l'habitant
quand je suis arrivé et puis on a super
sympathisé pour les trois ans ça reste
une coloc donc le soir on mange ensemble
l'avantage aussi c'est qu'en cas de
problème les étudiants ne sont pas
livrés à eux-mêmes moi en tout cas ici
je peux compter sur mes propriétaires là
par exemple mon ordinateur m'a lâché il
y a une semaine mais du coup j'ai pu
utiliser l'ordinateur pour faire mes
recherches d'emploi etc donc ça c'est
pratique maintenant qu'il a obtenu sa
licence Olivier entre chez lui en Vendée
à la recherche d'un travail et compte
bien renouveler l'expérience de la
colocation là-bas
pour les propriétaires leur est à la
recherche de nouveaux locataires cela
fait 6 ans qu'ils se sont lancés dans
cette expérience lorsque leurs deux
enfants sont partis de chez eux la
maison était grande quoi et puis
finalement ces jeunes je suis bien je
suis bien là je sais qu'ils ont il y a
une présence en bas et puis c'est
sympathique finalement c'est sympa parce
que bon ils ont besoin de quelque chose
ils montent là-haut on part en vacances
une garde la maison
vous êtes bricoler les mobylettes des
trucs comme ça
c'est la famille quoi ils le s'engage
pas cela leur permet aussi d'avoir un
complément de revenu il proposait jusque
là deux studios celui d'Olivier il y a
un autre un peu plus petit à 365 euros
toutes charges comprises dès la rentrée
il proposeront en plus ce tout nouveau
studio totalement indépendant pour 440
euros toute charge comprise quelques
conditions sont à respecter on tient
voir les parents parce que je vous comme
je vous dis on laisse notre maison
il y a le garage ils vont dans le garage
parce que ils se la machine à laver je
leur prête leur même à machine à laver
mon congélateur un petit peu donc ils
vont ils sont un peu comme chez eux quoi
finalement donc je vais avoir confiance
comme moi quand on parle un peu comme
tout étudiant non boursier leur
locataire pouvait bénéficier d'aide
financière tels que l'aide personnalisée
au logement versé par la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales elle est
variable selon le type de logement la
composition de la famille la situation
professionnelle ou encore les revenus
personnels d'aide de dernières années
pour les étudiants en alternance ou en
contrat de professionnalisation il y a
aussi une autre aide appelée le mobili
jeune ça peut être une aide
supplémentaire ça c'est déduction faite
de l'aide au logement qui est versé aux
jeunes donc voilà ça peut aller jusqu'à
100 euros par mois ce qui est pas
négligeable pas négligeable non plus
l'avance loca-pass elle permet à toute
étudiante ne pouvant pas financer son
dépôt de garantie de bénéficier d'une
avance gratuite ça peut faire lourd un
jeune
lorsqu'il arrive dans un logement de
sortir et un mois de dépôt de plus le
premier mois en cours calculer au
prorata bien sûr du nombre de jours qui
va faire et voilà ça peut être une somme
assez lourde donc il y a le dispositif
Loca-Pass qui peut l'aider l'avance
loca-pass donc ça veut dire que c'est
pas le jeune qui va avancer cette somme
là c'est le dispositif et c'est sous
forme de presse sans intérêt le jeune
rembourse ensuite en petite mensualité
le prêt qui lui avait été avancé 20
euros minimum par mois sur 36 mois
maximum d'après Lucile Guérin il vaut
mieux s'y prendre dès maintenant pour se
loger à la rentrée depuis le début de
l'année le service Yvelines informations
jeunesse a accueilli plus de 500 jeunes
créer son entreprise n'est pas une chose
facile comment on s'y prendre ou
chercher les financements quelle
démarche effectuée pour aider les
porteurs de projets la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des Yvelines
organise régulièrement des stages de
formation la prochaine session aura lieu
du 7 au 11 juillet à Versailles il
s'agit d'une formation payante mais vous
pouvez utiliser votre droit individuel à
la formation le fameux DIF renseignement
et inscriptions sur l'écran qui vient de
s'éteindre je remercie en tout cas de
nous avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine et très
bonne soirée à vous